it's a pleasure to be here as usual and
among friends I see so we're dead
already said my title and really this
this topic I want to discuss today
breaks down administrative ly into the
work of two excellent PhD students and
computational biology Mike Kramer who's
also getting an MD so he's about to
graduate than he has at least two more
years and probably many more on the md
side why you'd want to do that I don't
know but he'll be very powerful I'm sure
and then and then Mike you for the
second part of my talk who's somewhere
in the middle of his HD but but my
Kramer really talked about the
descriptive or did work furthering the
descriptive side of this challenge which
is how do we factor the cell efficiently
into a hierarchy of parts and and how do
we do that from data as opposed to
directly or indirectly from literature
and then my Q gets into how do you
functionalize this structure and that'll
be the second half another way of
viewing this though is really two phases
of of the same challenge in
computational biology and genomics so
the genomics view is that we now have
gobs and gobs of genome scale data as
you know you can represent those usually
as either a profile or a matrix or a
graphical model or a network and we have
lots of ways of analyzing these data
usually related to clustering and
classification but these genome scale
data we suspect are not only modular
that is to say a list of clusters but
they are also hierarchical and multi
scale and may contain far more
information about cell structure and
function than been our current say round
of clustering algorithms that's
challenge challenge one the flip side of
this is with respect to whatever one
might elusively call a wholesale model
sort of this desire to really understand
the complete structure and function of
the cell where I think we'd all agree we
need we still need a set of approaches
to do that namely to capture structure
and function of a hierarchy of cell
systems and my talk with regards to that
hierarchy prob
the most complete descriptive hierarchy
we currently have in the public domain
and it's widely used by everyone is of
course the gene ontology but as we know
this is not directly tied to data it's
in directly tied to data through manual
curation and and it's manual it's not
automated by and large and of course it
being descriptive it does not address
quantitative or predictive aspects so
let me talk first about the descriptive
aspect and then I'll get later to the
predictive aspect so descriptively it's
it's long bothered some of us that
networks are only really an abstract
model of the structure of a cell at best
they could of course be very useful but
but it's abstract and by way of meaning
what I mean is is if you open up the
hood of a cell it's not a wiring diagram
like that very different for instance
than if you open up opinion ship there's
a actual wiring diagram in there and
many other systems that are modeled by
networks there is an actual wiring
diagram in there in the cell there is of
course not an actual wiring diagram in
there if we look at what the actual
structure is that this network
represents I've can this to correspond
to all the subunits of the proteasome
which as you may know is sort of the
vacuum cleaner for proteins in the cell
it sucks up proteins and degrades them
here is the actual structure is
determined by millions of x-ray
crystallographic images and
computational methods that have been
worked out over the past 50 years to
integrate those and you're looking here
at sort of the side of this vacuum
cleaner tube so that it's sort of a side
view you can see there's multiple folds
of symmetry but there's also I want to
point out rich hierarchy so here in in
red and orange we have the so-called
core and and how it factors into
subunits at least structurally on the
outer edges of this thing or ends of the
tube we have the so-called regulatory
particle or aspects of this in blue and
purple the color coding I've made
correspond over here so you can see if
you were to apply a clustering algorithm
to the network or the core
spotting profile that underlies this
these data you might pull apart into two
clusters the red and orange apart from
the blue and purple and maybe their
structure beyond that but at least by I
it's it's very hard to pull it out so
one question is can we push the analysis
further from clustering to if not get at
the structure maybe that's eventually
possible through some type of data
integration scheme but at least for
today's talk and we at least push it to
see how much we can reveal about this
hierarchy of subsystems and subunits and
already for just the proteasome we have
at least three layers of hierarchy here
now as I mentioned of course the current
state of the art in hierarchies of the
cell is the go we all use it most of us
like it to a certain degree although
those of us who know something about a
particular biological process often
criticize it if you say oh they got it
all wrong here they got it all wrong
here or you know it's incomplete here or
you know what have you but nonetheless
it's it's I think all of us would agree
been incredibly central to the
discipline of genomics and
bioinformatics and so so what I think
they got right is this notion that we
should factor the cell in a systematic
sort of way into its component parts and
so here's sort of if you started at the
proteasome core complex there actually
are a couple of layers of hierarchy
below here but if I simply click on this
at the ebi and get what's above this in
the ontology of course you get this rich
hierarchical structure so a couple of
years ago it's three or four years ago
at this point my Kramer and and Jana
Zukowski my lab began to look at whether
or not there was first we're first of
all how close is the correspondence
between literature curated hierarchy and
hierarchies one can obtain directly from
omics data and then further having
established this kind of correspondence
went on to show that you can
recapitulate much of the known go
hierarchy directly from from data
through essentially a glorified
clustering procedure that I'll get into
in just a second but
dia is is if you climber if we put put
dance interaction networks together you
you can begin to define a hierarchy of
clusters and the question of course is
whether those correspond to to go an
early indication that that you would
have this correspondence was this figure
right here where we simply took in yeast
now and I should say or I guess
apologize that everything in my talk
today we'll all be sacrificing service
CA simply because if you want to study
this problem fundamentally there's far
more data both physically and
functionally for yeast than for any
other species without question so so
here we're looking at a physical or
biochemical protein interaction networks
in purple genetic or synthetic lethal
interaction networks in green simply
wiring together pairs of proteins whose
RNA levels are coexpressed over many
conditions and all that in comparison to
randomize networks and we're simply
taking the the go structure for yeast
the so-called go slim for yeast if you
guys know about that sort of thing and
ordering the terms in it by size which
is roughly like a layering of the go if
you think about it this is sort of the
lowest levels of the go in terms of a
hierarchical point of view and this is
near the top of the go there's about six
thousand genes beneath the root of this
of this go so that would be the upper
limit of the go and what you can see is
it for very small terms you have
actually quite striking enrichment for
physical interactions this is a log
scale here so so you know that's at
least fifty percent of gene pairs
assigned to terms of size less than
sixteen have already been documented to
physically interact using systematic
interaction mapping projects so that's
that's to me that was a large number and
and the second point here is that this
enrichment persists not just for
lower-level go terms or small go terms
like small protein complexes for
instance but medium-sized or medium
layer go terms like the ribosome which
might have 50 or 100 subunits and even
as you'll see in compared to random the
largest go terms like organ
Elle's mitochondrion for instance might
be a go term represented his size of
1024 so this was encouraging because it
told us that maybe there wasn't just the
correspondence but you could actually
put go aside for a moment reconstruct
the hierarchy and then get most of
what's already in go and has been in
comparison painstakingly created over
ten fifteen years so I already mentioned
to do this we use a glorified form of
clustering as you know there is lots of
hierarchical or agglomerated clustering
algorithms but by and large nearly all
of them for binary trees as a result of
their operation and so the idea is you
greedily pick the most two similar
objects in this case we're again in the
space of protein interactions genetic
interactions co-expression and other
kinds of systematic data one can gather
to create essentially gene-gene
similarities among all yeast genes and
and you can greedily cluster them to
form a binary tree but if one looks at
Go Go is not a binary tree it's a dag
that is to say there are terms and go
and and you can see here implicitly I'm
likening a join in this binary tree to
maybe a term and go with the difference
here that in the dag you can have terms
that have more than two children and
more than one parent so yes Mike various
guises why is the random the previous
slide rise the random flat
why is it good uh I think it just has I
think it's really it really just comes
down to if i randomly choose to protein
pairs now this has been about four years
since I published this but but if you
look it's basically if i randomly choose
to a pair of jeans then that's the
background chance they would interact
essentially okay so so the the glorified
clustering algorithm that we had to
develop does really two things it allows
for multi-way joins and it allows for
multiple parents and I think that there
may be a class of algorithms out there
that that have not yet been been
described they could do this better but
that's the sort of two features that I
think one needs for this class of
clustering algorithms in order to get
structures that aren't merely
computational inconvenient the binary
tree is merely a computational
requirement of the algorithm or by
product but butter actually structure is
reflecting the structure of the cell
that's that's the real goal here now
having done that now we have a data
constructed hierarchy versus the
literature curated gene ontology and
note that go has not been used to
construct this hierarchy how at all
however having constructed the hierarchy
one can now use it as a reference
against which to align the data-driven
object much like when you first sequence
a new genome when you run your gene
finding algorithms on that genome you
would first have a bunch of unknown
force you label them or if one or two or
three and so on by analogy we do the
same here when we first construct a new
data driven ontology of a particular set
of data here the yeast cell we at first
just name these term one term to term
three they're orphan terms if you like
but now through alignment against their
reference standard just like you would
align your genome and your yourse
against a reference which would be
GenBank or something and every time you
get a good sequence alignment and the
align sequence in the database is named
I just found
acton i just found what have you my
favorite gene based on the sequence
similarity you can now transfer all
english language knowledge over to that
that formerly orphaned gene now no
longer orphan gene and name it and so on
so so we can do the same with the gene
ontology alignment and here we didn't
invent any new algorithms but there's
already it turns out a collection of a
lot of ontology alignment algorithms not
in bioinformatics mind you but in other
disciplines of computer science that we
could avail ourselves of and just
briefly the way they work is they
compare labels on on the terms here the
label is just the list of jeans
underneath each term so we compare how
close the labels are and and have a
score that incorporates that but also in
sort of an e/m like fashion you look at
how good those alignments were for your
children and your parents and
simultaneously come up with a one-to-one
mapping or at least that's the idea is
to come up with a one-to-one mapping or
120 mapping you can simply fail to align
a term but you don't allow two terms to
align to a term for instance in the
other ontology so having done that we
can now begin to name some terms and
recognize them in our data driven
version as well as recognize which terms
are novel and which terms and go we
missed but first before I get to that
just to give some intuition about how
this thing works here's some unpublished
data for my Kramer's latest project he's
trying to publish it right now where
he's taken a case study of one
particular process that's in all of all
eukaryotic cells and certainly in yeast
it's called a autophagy it's the process
by which cells by jest other components
or components within the cell including
proteins it's been linked to stress
aging cancer and lots of other diseases
Alzheimer's for instance here are some
of the core autophagy genes in the
middle 80 g 27 through 24 as the name
would suggest that saw thapa ji and then
as outgroups to show you what dissimilar
jeans look like we we've put our f1 here
at one at the top and bck one and at the
bottom and what you're looking here in
terms of the heat map is an integrated
Jean jeans
molarity matrix from those protein
protein data the genetic interaction
data and so on so don't worry so much
about how we got that integrated gene
gene similarity matrix it's a
straightforward thing that lots of
people have described how to do to
integrate multiple data sets but you see
in the gene gene similarity space if you
went to cluster this into a discrete
flat set of clusters you'd run into
problems and have to make some arbitrary
decisions so for instance you would say
oh well you know atg three and seven
that forms the tight cluster okay ah but
7 12 and 10 also form a tight cluster
and 10 and 27 also form a tight cluster
so clearly we need to assign term or
jeans and also terms to to multiple
parents in this hierarchy and then we
really want to preserve the whole
hierarchy itself and not have to cut
this thing anywhere because you can see
a larger but weaker cluster here all the
way from apg 10 down to 80 pg8 so if you
see in the hierarchy and having now
built it and just aligned it directly
against go we can now begin to to find
these these structures and begin to name
them again from the go alignment so here
for 80 g 7 you can see here it gets
assigned to two parent quote unquote
terms one together with three and one
together with 12 and 10 and so on and so
forth and then this entire block gets
called core machinery of otology it
actually ends up a lining against a go
term called core machinery of autophagy
now I mentioned there's orphan terms
that is to say terms of aren't and go
here's one of them we had to just leave
it labeled term 183 its potential new
biology maybe it's a new protein complex
we'll have to find out and then the the
red border nodes here are terms that we
have now named but weren't originally n
go they now are being put and go i
believe they might already be in go we
have to look by our request and the
reason go put them right in is because
we already found several papers
supporting the creation of each of those
terms so here's one where we believe
from data there's a term there's no
paper supporting it so go won't put it
in
here's a case in these three cases here
where there were ample literature
already out there and and so we simply
sent the papers to the go editors and
they they viewed them and put these
terms in so hopefully that gives you a
feel for for how you begin to to build
these hierarchies and annotate them from
data or from the go and if you zoom out
and look at the whole hierarchy you
build for a yeast cell this is one
rendition of it the root of this
hierarchy is is up here you might
observe I promised you a dag this is
actually a tree it's not a binary tree
it but it is a tree simply to view this
whole thing we had to cut multiple
parents that we had to choose the most
important parent unfortunately you know
whenever there was more than one but
nonetheless unless you've lay out the
whole thing and talk about it and so you
can see here at the highest level what
happens is is you quickly based on data
now try for cade into a mitochondrion
membrane set of components and the
intracellular compartment those get
labeled directly by alignment to go that
reflects what's in go and and i think it
is remarkable that just based on sort of
protein-protein and genetic interaction
and coexpression similarity one can pull
apart and cluster out components at this
high of a level I think that is kind of
interesting and then notice that most of
the other labels that get put on
different parts of this structure again
by alignment to go calm down here in the
intracellular compartment probably
reflecting the simple fact that we've
studied as a field much more closely
what's inside this intracellular
compartment then what's at the membrane
or in the mitochondria now zooming
further if you recall I showed you the
structure of the proteasome let's look
at what the proteasome looks like and
now the the ontology that's been
constructed and that's over here recall
the data were this form if you visualize
them as a network but if you if you
process that data as an ontology here is
that region of the ontology that's up
towards the root there so notice again
I only put labels on on terms that have
been recognized and aligned to go so and
go we found the proteasome complex we've
factored the proteasome complex into
that core and regulatory particle you
saw in the structure and in turn what
you couldn't even see so closely in the
structure is the core itself well i
guess it was this was the orange and and
and yellow or red and orange I believe
subunits there we have an alpha beta
subunit the core factors into and
similarly the regulatory particle
factors into a base in a lid and then
maybe you have some other other aspects
of the proteasome here that aren't
exactly what's in go and whether those
are errors or novel discoveries is sort
of now is the opportunity the
opportunity arises that you can you can
look into that excellent excellent
question so so there's these three go
hierarchies biological process cell
component and molecular function
actually it's a good question because I
it's actually here it's my next slide so
we aligned against all three and and
this is this this view is with respect
to so neck so is what we call this
data-driven ontology Network extracted
ontology originally all those you'll see
my Kramer is renamed it but so is simply
looking in terms of the 1400 and two
terms in next so how many of those are
corresponding to a go biological process
a little component but like what
function term is shown there but to me
more revealing is to look with respect
to go what a fraction of go terms in
each of these three ontologies we
recover from data and here it's very
clear so here it looks like maybe it's a
biological process ontology but the
problem is there's far more terms in the
biological process ontology so in terms
of coverage of go you're sixty percent
roughly coverage of the cell component
side of go this is an unsupervised
approach and just a bit i'll show you
how Kramer has now tried to turn this
and do a supervised approach you can
target particular ontology ziff you like
but here and in this all the vagaries of
whatever decisions were made here we
to sell component now more recently a
few years ago now what no marching
forward a year or two and time Mike
Vinny boffin and I work together to try
to improve the algorithm and this is
more just an advertisement for this
paper I don't have time to go into the
details but just if I had to give you a
high-level novel aspect to this paper
versus the earlier work it's that it's
more error tolerance so we can add noise
both for false positives and false
negatives and and the precision and the
recall are much much more tolerant to to
to that error and so now now you'll see
sometimes it's weird click so which also
reflects a slight change in the way the
algorithm works this is called quick
extracted oncology's and it's it's
actually it's it's it's actually expired
from some of Road and Ron's work from
from way back where they use sort of
kalique detection as a way of clustering
and this is sort of hierarchical leak
detection if you want to look at it that
way okay so so so we we now are very
excited to use this approach to begin to
describe a variety of ontologies and the
question is how how does one begin to
use this in your say experimental
laboratory as a way of pushing forward
the biology sort of an active learning
sense if if you like and so so this this
slide partially summarizes what I've
said maybe now is sort of a template for
how one might apply such such a pipeline
and also how one might do it in a
systems biology cycle or in an active
learning sense so so the idea is you you
choose your favorite process in this
case for my kramer it saw thapa ji you
try to build a hierarchy of that process
using public data as much public data as
you can get your hands on you integrate
those data to derive a gene gene
similarity network and using this click
extracted algorithm i described just
sort of just alluded to you get a
hierarchy and or a dag which reflects
the structure of that data set now
typically by the way when one begins to
study a process in Experimental Biology
one doesn't incorporate prior knowledge
by the way one just says I'm going to go
do a big genetic interaction screen for
my favorite process why because I can so
we think one important change that needs
to happen in the field moving forward
and I'm now sort of addressing
experimentalists right is is take
advantage of all the data we've already
generated as a field to inform your
process as much as you can before you
start doing in experiments that's that's
point one but now having having built
the best model you can you believe it
with go to see how much how much of what
you of the public data sets are already
have reflected and go and how much
novelty there might already be maybe
you're done maybe already finds a novel
process or subcomponent here that you
want to study but if you want to study
more now the key would be can you can
you go back and and look at these
datasets across all the different omics
types of data and do some kind of
experimental guiding or selection as to
which new space of experiments might be
most fruitful for for building this
ontology by the way the entire ontology
for autophagy wasn't just that core I
showed you before it looks like this I'm
not going to go into all the detail here
here's the core component rehear but
just to point out even for a modest
process that's a 100 to 200 genes these
things get quite complicated nonetheless
when you sit down with your cell
biologist friends and here we're working
with the super Monte lab an expert in
autophagy we find that they really find
these diagrams intuitive and I'll show
you an example of some follow-ups
they've done in a second but first let
me let me address this experimental
design component so having built this
ontology and aligned it against go one
can now use that go alignment as sort of
a benchmark to talk about how
performance a particular data-driven
ontology is as you rode the different
data sets underlying it so when I say
fraction of maximum performance what I
really mean here is one is
is essentially the accuracy with which
I'm recovering the go branch of
autophagy with all the data and you can
looked at it how you decrease that
fraction as you pull out data and and
and we've looked at multiple ways of
pulling out data you can pull out
interactions by interaction and
qualitatively the results that i'm going
to show you don't change but here we
thought it was a little bit more
intuitive to pull it out study by study
so if you look at all the data that are
in yeast that inform protein-protein
interactions or genetic interactions or
poke expression and what have you and I
should say we simply borrowed ed mark
hots approach for doing this he has
something called yeast net if you've
heard of that essentially our data
integration scheme is just east net and
we freshened East net from what whenever
the paper was last published we added a
few more data sets but the algorithm is
the same there's I think eighty to a
hundred different studies quote unquote
that they summarized in and that that
work and we can pull them out one by one
according to their different types so
their studies of genetic interactions
protein interactions and so on and so
what you can see here is this thing is
somewhat sensitive to pulling out either
genetic interactions or protein protein
interactions there were only 10 verses
12 of those and this integrated data set
think about those papers but there's 50
coexpression papers interestingly you
can pull them all out and it has no
effect on your ability to reconstruct
the ontology so based on this and and
there's maybe other ways we could have
viewed oh ah and and the other the other
point that can be made here is you can
look at the absolute reduction of
performance but you can also look at the
slope and so based on on the slope even
though pulling out all protein-protein
interaction papers was slightly worse
than pulling out all genetic interaction
papers the instantaneous value of a
single new genetic interaction paper
seems slightly more valuable but again
you're really splitting hairs here both
both of these data sets appear quite
valuable and and combine that with the
fact that my lab has already the
experimental pipeline
to do genetic interactions in on
physical interactions it was an easy
decision for us we went in robotically
and generated a bunch of new genetic
interaction experimental data now
importantly even though Charlie Boone
and Brenda Andrews and others have
covered much of the space and I think
this afternoon we're going to hear about
how they've covered even more of the
space of genetic interactions at least
in terms of what's available to me right
now it's only about thirty percent so we
sought to fill in the other seventy
percent for autophagy but the other key
point here is we did it not just in
untreated conditions but because of the
fact we're studying a process that that
that has known stimulants we could look
at how those genetic interactions change
across otology relevant conditions and
so that's what's done here we have sort
of the untreated yeah we have the
untreated profile which I'm guessing on
a stage is going to just show us later
that's probably just a duplicate of what
she now has in the mother lode okay but
then we also have starvation rapamycin
and the differences between all of those
profiles so so in all we considered this
either three nudes experiments or six
new datasets however you it with some
covariance between them but but however
you want to view it
and so now we can look at how much those
new data that have been targeted both in
terms of the gene set and targeted
because of the conditions being relevant
to our process in influence our ability
to reconstruct on top as you go so just
to summarize here is what we had done
with all prior data and the first
iteration of the systems biology cycle
and this is just recapitulating
something I showed you earlier again
looking at how well we we recapitulate
knowledge and go here by the way you can
this this measure is reducing go itself
to a gene gene interaction at work using
this this resnet semantic similarity
measure some of you guys may know and
then just looking at how our edge scores
correlated with with theirs after either
before or after integrating with the new
data and you can see that what's
interesting is just looking at the gene
gene similarities just using our new
genetic interaction profiles alone do
better than all prior data a little bit
and so I think that if if there's an
explanation it's because we're targeting
towards this process as opposed to all
priori data which which largely does not
target this process but then of course
when you when you integrate the new data
with the old existing prior data then in
fact you can do even better and so
overall as a result of going one time
around the systems biology cycle we now
have a hierarchy that correlates would
go at the fifty percent level as opposed
to thirty percent level so we think
that's a substantial as well as
significant change of course if you
shuffle our new data then then you get
no correlation just to perform that
negative control and I mentioned that
that our collaborators find this a
particularly useful structure to sort of
look around to get new hypotheses for
experiments to do so just to show you
one of one of these there's a number of
things ongoing in the prior version of
the ontology constructed without the new
data set this they have this favorite
gene that they study a PG 26 it was
assigned to essentially the one of the
highest level terms in the in the
original version where
is after adding the new genetic
interaction profiling data and building
that new hierarchy aligning gets go and
so forth 8226 got placed much much more
specifically I'm just clipping out a
parent and a child term near the leaf of
this ontology so it got grouped
specifically together with these three
other autophagy genes nineteen twenty
seven and eleven suggesting that maybe a
PG 26 functions in the term that those
other genes were already annotated to
which was protein localization to the
pre autophagosome to prove that that's
probably the key or at least two
probably evidence in probably the case
they tagged the known pre autophagosome
well gene ATG 19 with gfp looked at how
it overlapped with the localization of
ATG 26 this new or a newly assigned
protein with another fluorescent dye and
what they're trying to show you here is
that these these two these two
components do not overlap in untreated
conditions which is probably why they've
been missed in interaction screens so
far but when you add rapamycin notice
the the cytoplasmic general location of
8226 sucks up into a punctate like
structure and now these two these two
overlap and so and and that combined
with a number of other experiments they
performed now lead us to believe that
8226 is indeed part of this this process
so I'm little more than halfway through
the the talk but I'm through the first
part and let me let me summarize the
descriptive part of this talk so maybe a
overriding theme here is that when we
look at these hair balls of molecular
interactions we're too close to the data
maybe it's it's really more akin to
trying to learn something about a
protein structure or the structure of a
protein complex like the proteasome by
looking at these x-ray diffraction
images certainly people do this and use
two more in the past but nowadays we
have a robust set of computational
algorithms largely known by
the name of structural proteomics that
converts millions of these types of
images into one of these structures that
one finds in npb PDB so I think the the
exciting idea here is that that maybe
we're in the same mode with with
networks we're really looking to
specifically at the data this is
somewhat sort of like the raw data or
close to the raw data and what we need
is a set of computational algorithms
that can reliably process these data if
not directly into the structure into
into data-driven ontology and and other
types of structures that inform overall
cell structure and and function
incidentally though i should say in the
proteomics field certainly not in my
work but in the proteomics field if you
here Rudy aebersold talk or any of those
those guys there's now a big push what's
in what's called chemical cross-linking
which is a way of measuring interactions
not just among whole proteins but among
peptides in those pairs of proteins that
Rudy and others think will maybe get you
somewhat closer at least to structure so
so that's that's the summary yeah good
before you move you move to another
subject please about noise so in when
when you're comparing now the structure
proteomics with let's say genetic
interactions protein interaction and so
on there is no is all the time and
you're you're extracting yes and the
more data you have the less noise you
have when you are doing the structure
proteomics however we know that they
both a genetic interaction network and
the protein interaction network is very
noisy false positives and false
negatives and one so at the higher
higher G it's very easy to eliminate the
noise or to disregard it but when you go
down in the air key then the noise
becomes really important I mean it's
very hard to see whether you have a new
genetic component absolutely completely
agree so but well I think the analogy is
actually quite good still to the
structural proteomics view so so the
more data you have the less de less
noise
and so the original idea of people like
Ed Markey marketing later Olga trance
kaya and so on and so forth who
integrate many lines of evidence to form
gene similarity networks is that each
line of evidence may have a certain
noise characteristic but that noise goes
down as you integrate more and more
lines of evidence over these different
kinds of networks so certainly we're
that's that's the key part of this
infrastructure here and and in this act
of learning sense the idea is to target
new data sets in a sense to where you
can clean up and make more stable some
of those those terms that's also why
Mike Kramer published that paper with
Vinny bhavna and I SMB two years ago is
really a exploration of how noise
influences this whole process so check
out that paper too not claiming we you
know had the final word on noise and in
this topic but but but we have sort of
thought a bit about it and I think it's
quite analogous to to structural
proteomics or to any any situation the
more averaging you do over many data
sets the better noise characteristic
you're going to have okay so let me know
in the last say 15 or so minutes flip to
this the second challenge that I
mentioned and this is Mike used projects
which is which is that oops networks and
ontology czar are mostly descriptive
maps I certainly go has been used in all
sorts of predictions but there's nothing
inherent about go where they go
structure that's predictive that's
that's the point however by the way we
happen to be reading this paper about
how Siri is constructed a few years ago
this is one of the last papers that the
authors of Siri published before they
got bought by by Apple and stopped
publishing papers I think these days
probably interest in ontology has given
way to deep learning and that kinds of
thing but nonetheless it remains that if
it when one speaks the command to agents
like Siri other agents ontology s have
long as many of you know been sort of a
cornerstone of how we process a query to
to give an answer and so for instance
this this is a
a piece of one of the many ontologies
that these guys at least now 10 years
ago had put in serie who knows what's
there now but at least in the early
version this was one of the the ontology
that Siri has as you speak to Siri Siri
is trying to take your voice commands
and slot those words in as states into
one of the many ontology it has in its
in its lexicon and somehow the most
probable fit is then the one that it
uses and so if any of these are not my
words not an original paper if if one
said sushi Siri find me a good sushi
restaurant tonight for two in my city la
jolla this might be the best fit to that
ontology and so you notice what's
happening here is the state of city now
becomes la jolla the style becomes sushi
party sites becomes too and so on and so
forth and based on that information Siri
can now back propagate and fill in terms
like state and zip code and and and up
the ontology can can can return answers
to your query like a list of restaurants
that meet these these state criteria so
the idea was why can't we do something
similar with go with go it's simply
descriptively used here here we have
both predictions and description that
are really being facilitated by ontology
so with Rodentia ron's group and mike
you embarked on the following project
which just by the way came out as cell
systems about a month ago so the idea
here is is now to go back to to yeast
and address queries of a very particular
kind but but but which capture the
general genotype-phenotype problem in
genetics and as you know lots of
problems in genetics one might even say
to a first order all problems in
genetics can be mapped to genotype being
a type prediction so again yeast it's a
great model to think about
functionalizing the go because again
because of those genetic interaction
then on a stage is going to be talking
about later we have even of this public
as of this publication about five
million genotype-phenotype pairs of the
form a pair of jeans is deleted and they
measure a growth rate a genetic
interaction experiment is essentially a
genotype phenotype relation that's the
point it's a particular kind that
involves disruption of exactly two genes
but we have lots of these pairs in fact
it's it's the it's by far the largest
unit type phenotype database that I'm
aware of so here's how we try to predict
growth given genotype using an ontology
structure and something akin to what i
showed you for siri and adding state to
terms I've now turned the ontology
upside down so the genes that the leaves
here are up and the root is down down
below but now imagine the game here is
to add States to terms which reflect
essentially some information about
whether the jeans underneath those terms
or here above those terms have been
disrupted so what one really wants in a
general sense is for a term to have an
activity state just like we can say a
gene knockout just rups and abrogates
the function of a gene what does that do
to the function of a term that's the
sort of set of latent variables we have
here one can imagine lots of ways one
might try to update the state of a term
or determine whether a term has been
disrupted given States on its children
here we used a couple of really simple
policies we tried a simple or gate so
basically a parent term gets disrupted
if any of its children are disrupted and
so on we also try to simply some simply
summing the number of genes assigned to
a term that have been disrupted but
again one could imagine in the future
lots of different schemes that one could
use to propagate function from from
genotype to phenotype here
while I'm on that topic the ontology
really does provide a nice bridge
between scales so if you think about
this what's the scale of genotype its
changes to nucleic acids which which are
sort of sub nanometer or nanometer scale
if you like and if you think about being
a type down here for a yeast cell it's
sort of overall growth characteristic of
the cell itself which is maybe ten
microns 100 microns were a human cell so
that's the scales we're going from
nanometer scale to tens of microns
ultimately one can imagine similar
schemes for predicting say human
phenotypes which would be a meter scale
so really what what the ontology here is
doing they call it the gene ontology or
its data driven cousin is it's it's
propagating perturbations at the
nanometer or two objects nanometers in
size two objects tens of nanometers in
size hundreds of nanometers in size all
the way up to your final phenotype scale
so it bridges these scales in quite of a
nice way now having so now that we have
some simple policy by which to set the
state of a term we can now translate a
genotype into what Mike you called an on
to type and an anon to type is the
complete set of states on all biological
objects in a Cell well genotype is the
complete set of states and all genes
salon to type includes genes it includes
phenotype and all objects in between
this is the idea and so here you can see
how on Tonto type begins to coalesce
different genotypes into similar or same
states so here is a toy example as a
simple one if you disrupt gene B&D from
the point of view of the odds Oh type
that is the same disruption as a
disruption of A&D why because a and B
are equivalent they are both assigned to
the same term here a minus one means one
disruption minus two means to
disruptions underneath that term and 0
means no disruptions given now this on
to type we now abandon any notion of a
whole cell model and simply you
straightforward class
regression and so now Mike used random
forest regression to regress these are
two types in a completely black box way
against the known phenotypes in a
cross-validation framework so so at
least we can push genotype using some
biological knowledge to on to type at
least at the present point in time in
our hands after on to type it's complete
machine learning now why why should this
work let me show you a very different
view of the same phenomenon if one takes
these genetic interactions that is to
say pairs of yeast genes that when
disrupted lead to a slow growth
phenotype one seized striking similarity
or correspondence to the go or
data-driven oncology's so just to give
you an example of what we saw that sort
of motivated this idea there if one
looks at genetic interactions there are
lots of genetic interactions between the
set of genes shown on the left and the
set of genes shown on the right that is
to say delete pair pairs of jeans across
those two sets and the cell doesn't grow
very well now in terms of the ontology
it offers a ready explanation for that
all of these genes are encoding kinesin
all of these genes are encoding dine
actin and earlier papers from my lab and
others would have called us between term
in Richmond but now that that between
term enrichment actually becomes with
interment Richmond at the next layer up
in the ontology because as you may know
both kinase and dine actin are part of
the microtubule-associated complexes so
with regard to the learning all of these
data would allow the machine to learn
that you know one disruption here
combined with one disruption here or
alternatively to disruptions here would
lead to slow growth and that's the kind
of kind of transfer function we're going
to try to learn so how well does it do
if we simply look at the at the growth
or interaction score predicted by by
this on to type procedure and look at in
cross-validation how well
recovers the measured interaction score
from Constanzo a towel we see pretty
good correlation it's about point 35 i
think point 3
so there's that if we substitute the
literature curated go for yeast with our
data driven version i present it in the
first half my talk recall that was
called neck so it actually doesn't do
quite as well but still way both of
those do way better than randomizing the
ontology the corresponding versions of
the ontology is a negative control and
as some of you know there's been lots of
efforts over the past ten years to try
to predict synthetic lethal using a
variety of schemes and and here was
we've compared against all of the ones
we sort of have you know find as
representative some of these are simply
newer versions of older ones and so we
didn't look at the older ones we looked
at the newer ones but all of these prior
approaches are non hierarchical they use
features in many cases many features but
not organized in this way what's what's
really cool I think about the current
approach is how simple it is there's
only one kind of feature at a term state
it's in contrast to some of these other
approaches that have sort of throw in
everything in the kitchen sink to try to
predict genetic interactions I'd like to
also point out that if we flatten our
ontologies by by reducing the the
ontology using semantic similarity to a
network and then apply sort of network
schemes it doesn't do as well so we
think in fact it really is something
about the hierarchical aspect but but i
do think more more studies are needed
and then if you want to look at this in
terms of if you prefer the correlation
something like a precision recall curve
of course if you look at sensitivity
specificity all these approaches look
fantastic just I'm not showing you the
ROC curve not because it's bad it's just
too good and the reason is too good by
the way if you care is this is a very
unbalanced learning problems so there's
far more the vast majority of pairwise
gene disruptions have no phenotypic
effect everyone gets it much like we get
it okay so look at precision recall and
it really showed it really it really
keeps you honest about how all these
things are doing ok so now one can begin
to look back though in it and try to
interpret the anto types or the
prediction
process so just before I scale up to a
larger example let me focus on on again
this one eye and just to see the color
coding I'm using here so as we browse
around this functionalized ontology
we're going to look at at terms that
enrich for lots of positive or negative
interactions and so this shows that this
term in riches for lots of both and then
we're going to look at how those
enriched interactions factor among the
children and children's children of
those processes this is the sub the
subsystems underneath that term and so
here's another good example is it's
quite intuitive that gets pulled out you
find that oxidative phosphorylation and
riches for both positive and negative
interactions but the positive ones all
go this way so keep in mind a positive
interaction is is to disruptions that
actually produce better than expected
growth a negative interaction is to
disruptions that Bruce worse than
expected growth so here you can hit hit
electron coupled transport or until the
cows come home essentially lose twice
and the cells fine okay but if you hit
one here and one here the cells dead and
and at this later you wouldn't have seen
that you only see that explanation here
is you now you can begin to see how
that's going to convert into an to type
logic in the machine learning here's a
bigger example DNA repair a process more
near and dear to my heart so here DNA
repair is a term in riches for lots of
interactions both pods mostly negative
is some positive but then if one looks
at the subsystems involved in DNA repair
double-stranded break repair
recombinational repair mismatch repair
nucleotide and so on and so forth one
sees the blue the positive pushes all
the way down essentially to synthesis
dependence stranded kneeling so you can
hit this process essentially what's
happening as one hit to this process has
the effects on phenotype multiple hits
don't matter where is there's lots of
semi redundancy or synergy across pairs
of DNA repair pathways much like we
might expect but again you can now see
how all that logic can then be converted
into into a
a prediction of growth yeah do you have
an actual synthetic recipe to this logic
so a synthetic can you can you define
for me what you mean by synthetic rescue
that signally create a bad growth
phenotype you put them together and
there is no effect on each other I mean
the problem is for us at this layer that
just looks like a positive that gets
treated the same as any other positive
epistatic interaction and we're not
going to be able to distinguish it in
the current framework now I think what
you've just done is is made a suggestion
for future work for how if depending on
the score is one gives this thing for
learning you know 11 could maybe learn
those effects to be separate from from
straight epistasis but the last slide I
want to show here is just is i think to
remind us here that this is really not I
focused a lot on prediction of genetic
interactions because that's the data I
currently have and large number for
genotype phenotype but just wanna remind
people this this system is not
restricted to prediction of just
pairwise gene disruption phenotypes it
converts any genotype simple or complex
into a non to type which is then used
for prediction so there is one paper we
could found from Devon crogans group
that looks at three it's a large-ish
screen for three-way interactions and I
won't go into the details of that study
but basically what's shown here just
like I was correlating our predictions
versus the measurements before these are
pairwise and triple deletions and you
can see here that what happened in their
hands is is the double deletions
involving the gene kak one and any
subunit of the her complex lead to slow
growth there's four subunits of her
that's why it was four points but that
was rescued by addition of another
deletion at asf one so those the circles
go up to the squares where there's
really no phenotype effect on growth and
so we were pleased to find that our
system without any training maybe we got
lucky we probably got a little lucky but
nonetheless in the one example out there
are a study of three-way interactions we
can predict that effect and what's
basically happening is shown here
breaking down the structure of the go
and the function that's then ascribed
that go and you can see how the
prediction is made essentially all of
these genes fall under chromatin
organization all three of them are
ascribed the nucleosome organization but
only two of them to DNA replication
independent nucleosomes simply and so
what basically happens is if you hit DNA
replication nucleosome assembly twice
then essentially that that cripples the
cells so bad you can't observe any more
phenotypes in the end and so there's no
interaction prediction but if you sort
of hit it once in one knee but not the
other now it's crippled but still
functional enough that you can reveal
phenotypes within nucleosomes
organization in which case two hits but
not one to nucleosomes ation kill you so
is this complicated yes but did the
machine learn that complication yes so
to summarize this last part of the talk
what and by the way so I'm showing off
I'm sorry but we're happy with this the
editor said this was the most
psychedelic image she had ever seen you
know kind of thing but the idea here is
is that that perturbations two cells at
the nanometer scale on two genes can be
converted to observations of
perturbation at the micron or meter
scale the level of cells and maybe
eventually people and one convenient
structure for for connecting or bridging
those scales is the gene ontology
because it really captures a small you
know aggregations of gene products and
small protein complexes larger complexes
pathways organelles and finally cells in
a way that they can propagate or
aggregate mutations from small funnels
to large funnels and so on and so forth
so so like the first part of the talk I
don't you know think that the algorithms
were using now or the algorithms that
will be used next year even
but I do think there may be suggestive
of work that needs to be done it might
be quite exciting and so with that I've
already I think thanked hopefully
everyone involved or the key players
involved as I went along certainly i'm
thankful for key collaborations with the
boffin of sharada and super Monte labs
and I'll be happy to take any questions
your earliest signs you community though
several compartment molecular function
biological process yeah and the seminal
function seems to do a lot better a cell
component in the unsupervised mode I
yeah and I and later in the autocracy
piece I slipped in a supervised approach
without explaining it but but it was
that the question you had or was there
another question yeah so why is cellular
compartments so much better than reality
so when that study that that so I
thought a bit about that I think it's
just that you you saw that that these
ontology construction procedures is
appear to be driven by protein-protein
interactions and genetic interactions
and less by gene expression at least in
our in our in one way of analyzing it
and if you look at at what is in the
cell component branch of go it's there's
a lot of protein complexes yeah so so
you know bio bio chemical interactions
may be best predict cell component
that's that's my guess and he said oh so
most
yeah and so and so you know if you
recall when when we were predicting
genetic interactions that is to say
genotype 14 entire phenotype and
genotype we tried both the data-driven
ontology and the go and they worked
about the same that go work a little bit
better but the data-driven ontology
again is based on the same kind of
information I do think the way forward
here just like we always have
structure-function relationships in
biology I think the way forward is to
build the gross structure from
structural data so not genetics it
originally we threw it all in now I
think that might have been a mistake I
think maybe what what you know we should
do is keep the the structural
information separate build the hierarchy
and then functionalize that hierarchy
and a later step using pure genetics
that's not what is done here well
certainly in the in the in the last part
we had the show that we weren't
predicting genetic interaction just
because we built off of genetic but but
having done that we weren't quite as
pure about my daughter's I think people
should be
oh well dad yeah I mitrice yeah early
question using is physical for you to
take into account a little noise when
you put different information together
yes so there is so in this click so
paper that that was what that paper is
about there's there's a there's a
there's one parameter called alpha that
you can use to dial your error tolerance
I'm nervous about this parameter by the
way but but there is I there is a
parameter but for the ontology juicing
would be good to putting that's kind of
indications yeah so so actually hey and
you know I forgot one thing so let me
show you what we're building George
might displays here
so so it in so we're trying to come up
with an online version of these
ontologies that can be browsed so here's
the one that michael kramer works with
my cytoscape dies too to build its work
in progress but but we're trying to put
information in here about how robust the
term is there's different ways in
addition this noise parameter there's
different ways of assessing there were
busting to determine data and the
original paper in nature biotech we use
the bootstrapping base two procedures
you can imagine bootstrapping the gene
similarity matrix you at the beginning
and then doing that a thousand times and
constructing a thousand ontology and now
aligning them all against each other or
at least against the unvoiced raft one
and looking at how often a particular
term is recovered and one can do that
and and it's quite useful because then
for you know as an experimental
biologists what you want to do is look
at what are all the terms that have the
worst Lima score against go but the most
robustness in bootstrapping and those
are where I want to a direct my my my my
novel experiments thanks for the me that
that's a great question thanks for
forcing me to talk about that but but
then I had mentioned the show you know
you can kind of browse around this
ontology online you know and it's this
has been quite useful to work with our
collaborators on so if we kind of zoom
in here you know to this autophagy one
let's just click on a term so cell
proliferation who due to the low that's
supposed to be a much smaller part of my
screen but you know it's a low res
projector so now when I click on that
when I'm now looking at inside escaped
Jas is the actual raw data that
supported the influence of the term but
I just clicked on and then one can can
come down here oops
and if you want to know what are each of
those interactions and get back to a
paper one can click on those pubmed ids
and so on and so forth and i think this
is also going to be i don't know if it's
in here yet but it's going to be a good
place to talk about well we have we have
score went and we give you nothing about
what that score actually is but it's
it's related to the issues you ask that
oh I need Theresa yeah and I know that
the file is god post your confession and
go Oh some very static concept you
envision moving towards a dynamic was
this type of this type of here I guess I
guess if there was a dynamic part about
the vision I talk about it was the issue
of doing more experiments and how you
guide more and more experiments as you
go through but I think you're getting on
to to do you build what the right policy
do we build these for every condition
space i mean you know and it's
interesting because the go project is
struggled with this for years system in
terms of using it in the prediction of
the dynamic response of the system or
event but to sell dynamic right for me
it's like static genotype i'm taking a
very genetic view of life right i have
genotypes and phenotypes whereas you're
sort of taking the biochemical view of i
have phenotypes that are dynamic
responses to things including
environments right how do I handle that
and I really other than have noticing
the glaring omission I've done nothing
to address it
what do you think well I was wondering
whatever you have at it not as beautiful
as it is I was wondering whether you
have a vision how to look in that area
so we've been talking about yes so we've
been talking about this I mean 11 you
know publishing that first nexo paper
put us into kind of an interesting
relationship with the go team that that
I'm happy to say was resolved and and
and we're actually not working together
in in various ways and you know they
they it's interesting to hear to sit on
their their meetings and hear their
discussions because I mean they
basically feel that for instance Mike
cherry fields yeast is covered he's
covered every paper in the literature
it's done where his duty Blake feels
like she's got tens of thousands of
miles papers that are uncreated right
for instance but but then they talk
about dynamics and they talk about is
was it really the right decision to have
three branches I've no longer sure it is
i think there needs to be one factor you
know a physical factoring and you need
to functionalize that I that's my vision
for what needs to happen I don't think
we need these three branches anymore but
again you're talking about yet another
issue which is you know there was
originally in the original David
Botstein paper right there was there was
it was called a tool for the unification
of all biology and they were very
adamant there must be one go not one go
/ even species right was one go for all
of biology but then later they relaxed
that a little bit but but and this
decision also led to interesting
consequences like you have terms that
are like conditions specific terms like
formation of this complex under
rapamycin just doesn't make a lot of
sense so anyway I think you're asking
very good questions
yep that's right so in your autophagy
example and some of the others you had
protein complex as you infer that had
just two components right so two
proteins yeah that's the bevy the
smallest unit that's not just a gene
right just a single physical interaction
which is an edge in your network yeah
they're here let's look at select this
thing here this got to be what
interaction right let's go up yeah right
there's an example right right I guess
I'm maybe sort of wondering what is
really the definition of a protein
complex oh I know why don't we call all
edges in the graph protein complex it's
like we're there must be some physical
distinction or I mean go added it in
there you said because there was a paper
that supported that complex you know
what's for some of these well some of
these there in go why you know what
every pair interaction we could call a
complex but we don't do that I'm seem to
have some notion that there has to be
some larger functional been going on to
make a bigger complex where does one
sort of draw the line well one doesn't
draw the line when just keeps the whole
hierarchy right but but there's but
certainly if you're talking about are
you talk about the gene ontology or how
we shall things should be I guess yeah
yeah yeah I mean you know so what about
us a complex that has four different
subunits that all behave let's just be
theoretically but I'll behave exactly
redundantly but there are four different
genes you should the correct thing to do
is to merge them all for once into a
term where is the interaction graph
it'll come out as a click if you're
lucky what do you look no I decide you
have many of these approximate gleeks
you know that our service that's how it
works and that's exactly how this works
mash together in some way that's but
that's but that's exactly what this is
doing it's detecting systematically
those those nested clicks using using
using a error parameter phrase looks
like experimental you know
characterization that allows one to say
that these this grouping of four is what
I should call the complex and not this
visit how does one then validate that
but yeah so one can do a pull down so so
so so here's a peers an example so a lot
of protein-protein interaction data are
shown as flat interaction pairwise
interaction graphs but the actual
experiment is not is not so so in a PMS
that's experiment you have an antibody
against one of your proteins let's say
one of those four and the other three
are identified in that pull down so
that's actually asset-based experiment
not and we've been showing it as a graph
but and then you know [ __ ] knows we've
you know there's like papers on this
arguing about how you represent this
data in a graphical framework but but
this doesn't even try hey this is right
right because many times you have
protein a interacting sometimes with
protein B and sometimes with protein C
and many times you have protein a B and
C being a complex and at this stage we
cannot distinguish between them neither
experimentally nor computationally right
and so that leads to a lot of trans
transitive interactions which are wrong
which are actually not exactly okay but
we assume that they are because of the
way we collect the data yeah and and the
other point I would make is even taurus
there is information that this thing
uses or one can use even for a single
pair which is the string to that
interaction because keep in mind your
first integrating lots of information
would like the mark hot way of like 80
different lines of evidence and so the
gene similarities actually every was
sent in a first degree every pair of
jeans has a score now now I have to
admit that the actual computational
procedure would be crushed if we if we
took that complete graph as input and it
clicked so we actually have a first at I
sort of ad hoc threshold arret accompli
graph that you start with with different
ways
so there may be one less one of the
earlier questions to thinking about like
context so Fergie's that maybe I mean
you have different environmental context
but it's not like it multicellular
organism so we think about a
multicellular organism do I have like a
liver and XO van a skin next yeah well
this this kind of gets back to Teresa's
question as well the go people would say
no but you can certainly now do it I
guess you know I don't know but i but
but you can do it now you know that's
maybe the right answer so far everything
which is in your cluster need I'm just G
so how about you screw it in those
conditions as knows that you learn yeah
yeah yeah yeah I thought a bit about
this yes no protein and they may be able
to provide the context that's got me you
see yes yes no missus plaster and come
work at complex exactly so maybe maybe
that's how to do it is if everyone heard
the services have terms or nodes that
are somehow conditional in pipe yeah I
think it's great what do you want